freeze i'm in do you want to go over the
rules one more time no no
new new
i'm looking in my wallet for money so
you can tell me my fortune
i promise it's worth it oh i can see you
walking out of here and you're thrilled
with your reading
what are you
michael what did you tell him nothing
then why are his hands up
bill he told me he couldn't show it to
me but he has a gun
okay let's call it a day you're good
that's good good work everybody my
mother
cried the day i was born because she
knew she would never be better than me
at any given moment i'm thinking about
one thing richard dreyfuss hunkered over
eating dog food i feel like i'm the
paris
of people what exactly is the chain of
command
vis-a-vis on-site response hmm you know
what why don't we just say
that whoever gets to the emergency first
will be in charge
okay so if there's an explosion say in
ramsett park and someone from sewage
gets there first
they'd be in charge remix yo
[Music]
throw
what's happening i think they're
laughing at you that's never happened
before
i don't like it got it
i know you think getting in trouble is
cool
but let me show you what can happen if
you continue down this path
hey yo i'm an at-risk kid and i think
it's cool to sell
drugs hold up why does a kid selling
drugs sound like he's black
he's not well why not are you saying
that black people
can't sell drugs no i'm not saying that
we have a black president
why can't black people sell drugs i'm so
confused
black people can sell drugs black people
can't sell
jokes black people can't sell drugs
black people can't sell drugs
black people can't sell drugs black
people can't sell drugs
i hooked up with his boss
who ron that guy's an extra on the show
no he said he was jack's boss in the
sketch
he doesn't even have a line he doesn't
have lines
don't eat in costume give me a prank
oh check this out my key to the city of
gary indiana
um look at this and my gold record from
that novelty party song
[Music]
spooky scary points becoming
[Music]
uh my bad y'all that reaction was very
out of character for me
um normally a very cool guy i have a lot
of
cool sneakers and a very active sex life
welcome to animal control let me show
you around those are some chairs that's
a cat or
possum oh this is a napkin
where i wrote down a cool name for a dog
bark obama
right is that what's happening here oh
yo
yeah we found this bird outside we tried
to turn it into a work whistle like in
the beginning of the flintstones
tougher than it looked though we have a
massive pest problem in this town and
it's because the animal control
department has been a disaster
at catching animals they're great at
ingesting and selling marijuana
this place is a miserable suck hole run
by two pothead losers
it's completely and utterly mismanaged
thanks
it does seem to be very poorly run but
we've only been here for two minutes
there may be a method to their madness
there's more than one way to skin a cat
four there's four ways to skin a cat
ready
what is this coyote trap dude this hurts
yeah we got like a huge vermin problem i
mean we've been meaning to call somebody
about it but you know nobody get on the
phone
you're the people you would be calling
that is so trippy
ow you're fired you're fired the whole
department is fired oh this hurts this
was one of my running feet
yo let's go to jamaica no we should go
to jamaica oh is that what you said
if anyone out there is listening i'm
being held here against my will
i'm a minor
you ready to give me my discount now no
okay what have you been doing in here
this whole time what kind of business is
this
we're a paper company the best paper
company in the whole wide world right
do i knock it off you'd better think
about what you were doing young man
you better think about what you're doing
no i'm an adult
i don't have to think or do anything
you're a kid
you're a little snot-nosed punk kid who
thinks he's better than everybody else
because he's some hot shot and you don't
know anything about sales
so stop being a disrespectful little
jerk okay sales
yes sales you sell pizza last time i
checked that's called sales you're such
a loser
what did you just call him a loser what
did you say a loser what i wasn't
okay stop does that work stop say it
you just made this worse a whole lot
worse this one is hand-in-hand all right
girls break it up you're being
infiltrated
[ __ ] in the hen house cock's in the hen
house don't say cox where'd you go to
school bishop o'hara piss slop who cares
we played you you you really look
familiar did you uh
you cheered for them didn't you no
yes i did
[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is dwight and i would like to
buy a purse from you
good lord look at these purses this is
something special oh my god is this
salvatore
pasta oh definitely definitely step in
and out of it like that
yes yeah well i want to stress test it
you know
in case anything happens oh
that was really this is necessary to do
to really give it a good workout this is
the oh
this is the prettiest one of all i'm
gonna be the prettiest girl in the ball
oh how much oh god it's sad
it's so sad
you